On one occasion, on one of those
frequent trips to Buenos Aires, I was
eating with Professor Victor Fan at
the well-known La Biela restaurant, which is in
front of the Recoleta Cemetery, the
cemetery where
the remains of my virtual father rest.
he asked me to accompany him because he wanted to say
a prayer in front
of my father's grave for my father's soul
I am not very fond of going to
cemeteries and in reality I did not know
where the grave was between we walked
long distances trying to find it
someone who could tell me where it was and I
felt a certain a certain shame
of not knowing where my father's grave was
and that the teacher to do there
until I came up with a little
lie to get out of trouble
choose teacher the grave the mausoleum
the cemetery is very far away it is very
big we are going to be late for the
conference symbolically we offer a
prayer here I stopped and we prayed together for
me  father in that cemetery but in front of
any tomb life gave me the
opportunity to be able to fulfill that
prayer in front of my father's tomb and
none other than with alex
the grandson of victor frank and dear friend of
mine and he asked me to tell this
anecdote  And I never thought that this
anecdote would mean that with
Fran's grandson
I was able to do what I couldn't do with
convicts, thank you very much
Álex